all the media they're extremely
frustrated by the success of President
Trump despite two years of an
investigation that went nowhere and now
they're moving from an obsession over
impeachment to this we know he he broke
the law y know he was a criminal as far
as obstruction of justice here's the
answer you take it from a binary choice
of two lanes you create a third Lane you
take the word impeachment and you change
it to criminal activity you agree that
the headline here is president Trump
likely committed a crime but I could not
charge him because of the legal guidance
that sitting presidents can't be charged
yes I think he finally made it crystal
clear well so basically impeachment it's
just not good enough anymore
or maybe not politically palatable
joining me now is former Speaker of the
House host of the new podcast newts
world and Fox News contributor Newt
Gingrich thanks for being with us
tonight Newt do you think that this will
hurt Democrats in 2020 if they end up
pushing forward on this sure I think
they look nuts
I mean mauler himself look nuts you come
out and you say you know the Russians
that we've indicted are innocent until
proven guilty
but now the president we haven't proven
him innocent yet there's when just think
about that that paragraph and what
Mueller said and now you got the
Democrats who are saying all right well
maybe we can't impeach him but we all
know he's a criminal well how do they
know that but I think you have to start
out where the fascist left is free
speech means you're not allowed to speak
they a whole model of the way they deal
with things if you say anything wrong
you neither homophobic Islamophobic you
know something and so they're not their
normal behaviors to just make stuff up
there's no evidence that the president
has been guilty of anything and that's
you had two years Moeller had 15
left-wing democratic lawyers all of them
by the way very good prosecutors he had
I think thirty million dollars he locked
up at least two people in solitary
confinement
for lengths of time that frankly are on
American and he couldn't find anything
now at that point the Democrats are to
go on and talk about policy and
recognize that this is this is really a
dry hole they're not they're not going
to get anything good out of this oh it's
interesting that you mentioned the
policy deal Newt because even some
Democrats who are pretty lefty are
getting a little frustrated by the fact
that they when they're invited on TV
shows or to speak to the media the
policies are the issues that they want
to talk about there being a clip so brad
Sherman experienced this yesterday on
MSNBC I've been trying to get on your
show to talk about the Saudi nuclear
program and if it was my time we'd be
talking about efforts to control drug
prices there's this image in the country
that Congress is focused only on
impeachment that's the only thing I can
get on TV to talk about but it's not
really what I'm working on so do you
think that more Democrats are gonna
continue to maybe push back on this
because we're gonna get to this later we
talked about this the issue with the the
polls president Trump's polls are are
going up in key metrics key ways I just
get the sense that people are onto this
whole game now I mean they're onto the
fact that the Democrats aren't
interested in to me they're interested
in demonizing that's what they do look
we just had a referendum on the news
media and the news media lost I mean
that's the number one thing of the last
two years they did ever really three
years kind of the campaign they did
everything they could to destroy Trump
he's still president he's improving in
his poll numbers the economy is growing
and on most major issues the country is
much closer to Trump than it is to
radical Democrats so I think it's a very
different environment than Democrats
thought they'd be in and my predict
you're going to see a Republican Senate
passing positive legislation and Pelosi
is over here with a divided house
Democratic party part of which wants to
spend all day every day attacking Donald
Trump and part of what's frankly out of
survival wants to pass something and I
wouldn't be at all surprised to see
Kevin McCarthy begin to form an alliance
with 30 or
Democrats answers whose own re-election
is at stake if they stay negative yeah
well look at all these Democrats we're
doing a continuing series on basically
doing an update on the so-called
moderate Democrats and somebody them
pledged to work with Trump and then push
comes to shove they're not working with
Trump so I think that's an excellent
point and new part of this new
substantive issue that Trump is tackling
is the border which you and I have been
talking about for years and the
situation is untenable beyond it's
beyond crisis almost every measure is
beyond crisis what about the decision to
slap the 5% tariffs on Mexican goods
effective June 10th unless Mexico does
more to stem this massive tide of
humanity coming up from mostly the
northern triangle countries no other
things that's going to be part of
Trump's legacy that historians are gonna
write about is that he just has common
sense and he follows projects through
like just exactly like the kind of
businessman that he was so none of these
people would be on the American border
if they weren't coming through Mexico
moving stopped people will come by boat
or by airplane and so without Mexican
compliance all of these people would
still be down in Central America and I
think this is the first time we've seen
an American president who said well and
by the way the Democrats in Congress are
forcing him into this position because
they refuse to do the common-sense
things which are fund the Border Patrol
and build the wall and allow us to
contain things so the president has said
look if you're not going to help me that
I can use my authority to put so much
pressure on Mexico now candidly if he
then moves to cut off sending money to
Mexico which he could do you would then
see an enormous crisis in the Mexican
economy we have a lot of Republican
senators at least some who are against
these tariffs Chuck Grassley Portman
Joni Ernst to me Tumi's against any
tariff ever I mean he's apparently fine
with China winning on it every front or
at least it seems that way but a lot of
these farmers are being hurt
by the soybean tariffs China's can't you
know China's you know not getting and
not buying them it's hurting them and
how long how much pain is really being
inflicted on the American consumer and
how long can this administration hold
out I mean I think I completely agree
with what they're doing on tariffs but
I'm hearing from all these Wall Street
people who do a lot of work in China for
instance like how this is really hurting
us it's like yeah because you're doing
all these deals with with Communist
China maybe we should stop doing with
them well there are a number of
billionaires who love China because
that's where they got to be billionaires
I would simply hope that the president
will presently say let's take as much of
the Chinese tariff money as we need to
and we will divert it to the American
farmers so we use the Chinese tariff
payments in order to take care of the
farmers who the Chinese are trying to
rip off and I think if he did that and
did it on a large enough scale that it
would become a non-issue but the truth
is in the long run China cannot win a
trade war with the United States it's
simply not possible there are too many
other countries we can go to in order to
buy things we're going to the Chinese
are going to build a whole series of
competitors in Asia in places like
Thailand and Vietnam and the Philippines
and they're just going to lose market
share and at the same time now we're
gonna find out that we don't need them
now we don't need them on most most
things but you know the soybean farmers
they're always going to get the
attention that on other networks because
it looks like it's gonna hurt Trump but
I mean our economy versus the Chinese is
not gonna be in the lopsided trade it
definitely doesn't hurt I was just do
the math but if the president's right
and the number of billions of dollars
he's talking about he could afford to
double the income of every soybean
farmer in the United States just taking
a linear out of the Chinese tariff and
sent a little note saying you might want
to send a note to Gigi and ping thanking
him the amount of money he's now sending
you all right thank you so much for
joining us and I really appreciate you
staying out